imagine if all right you cut this cost
it's gonna be real lab I won't set
I'm not causing the bfx and I like how
that
if you don't pay me I'm wearing the
dynamite vest
[Music]
all right so we've already talked about
this topic before on this show but there
has been an update oh wee-wee Alec
Baldwin it's looking like he's going to
be charged with involuntary manslaughter
in the rust shooting death I actually
like this what does that look like I
don't know I don't know how to make
sense of it I don't know any what that
means like what jail time or whatever
because that that part makes me sad 18
months and like five thousand dollars
for one option and another one is five I
think five years yeah something like
that I like it because he did actually
kill someone and it almost seemed like
oh big Hollywood guy got away with it or
like oh like there's no gun that's going
to shoot itself or anything like that
and then it almost felt like he they
paid like the husband hush money like
I'm actually happy my wife died like
there's that one interview where he like
was like what the [__] did how much did
they pay you to say [__] like that so I
feel like this is actually good where
you even if you're huge you can't just
get away with [__] did that really
happen yeah there's an interview where
he says that I mean he didn't say like
that but that's what you're saying with
his face yeah
his face was like why are we talking
about that no no his face was more like
yeah so I guess um is coming down I
guess I'm a producer on the movie now
like that like I get producer credit
though
but you're just like that's a lot of
[__] [__] things under the table
going around dang that's how I read it
at least I don't know maybe Alec Baldwin
on that movie was also a producer right
yeah so he's actually being charged with
both an actor and a producer on the
movie
um the district attorney says that he
pulled the trigger at the actor and he
had a duty to make sure the set was safe
as if that's the thing I think a lot of
people don't understand like a lot of
angry people that are commenting like he
didn't do it he's given the gun it's
like dude as a producer you have a
responsibility too and also a gun's not
gonna fire unless you pull the trigger
and what about the not the gun
so she also we have to say that but yeah
so prosecutors in Santa Fe county made
the announcement Thursday morning that
Baldwin will be charged with involuntary
manslaughter and the film's head armorer
Hannah Gutierrez was also charged
accountable yeah she's also charged with
involuntary manslaughter water both face
a maximum of five years in prison if
convicted I just don't know how they can
put a bullet inside because it's clearly
a from a blank to like a like it's just
I don't know how you could just be like
loading it up and then being like well
it's like her fault for not managing the
weapons properly and then she hands it
to the guy who says okay this is a cold
gun yeah and then gives it to him
um and then he's like okay well it's a
cold gun and he has his finger could
have slipped yeah regardless like you're
never gonna put your
they train you to not put your fingers
on the trigger it's called Trigger
Discipline
and on top of that you're never supposed
to point it directly at the soul of
someone everybody did their job
correctly or if just one person did
their job correctly the situation
wouldn't happen that's all three [__]
and it's because but at the end of the
day it does go up to the producer who's
supposed to keep in line with every
single it's your project yeah right yeah
the D.A says Alec definitely pulled the
trigger despite what he says because she
trusts the FBI's analysis and she says
one of the reasons the investigation
took so long was because prosecutors
were waiting to see what the FBI
concluded about the government he's
saying he didn't pull that part that's
weird he's like it just went off
yeah it went back Alex uh Alex attorney
released a statement saying this
decision distorts Helena Hutchins tragic
death and represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him the
gun did not have live rounds we will
fight these charges and we will win
[__] because there's multiple other
instances because I know people who were
on that set that things went wrong even
in that department this is just the main
thing that's being what are other like
examples but they've been so so but then
personal clothes from the rumors that
you've heard allegedly you can get you
can get from the rumors that you heard
they've been incompetent in many
different things
and there was live ammunition and they
were firing stuff why because for fun
they're just like maybe baby all right
so they're just mixing the volume and
they were just there's no
um real allegedly there's no real
regulation between that so they're just
in the back [__] shooting bottles and
they're like all right time to shoot and
then let's switch the [__] gun which
gun's witch
they wanted to cut [__] gun is a gun is
a gun like a 20 difference or something
like this allegedly between the armorers
and so that's why they brought her on
what he does it was like something
stupid like Barry might do like 20 per
hour or something like that yeah
something like that
um and so because they wanted to cut
coffee it adds up imagine if all right
you cut this cost there's gonna be real
lab I won't set
[Laughter]
if you don't pay me I'm wearing the
dynamite vest
it's like extortion
for an extra 20 bucks I'll get rid of
all the ammo pretty much the logic of
these people
this is like such a textbook thing of
like hey if these things aren't in place
and these things don't happen here's the
result it's so plain textbook like
that's the one to follow the rules yeah
the assistant director Dave Halls has
agreed to a plea deal for the charge of
negligent use of a deadly weapon he will
get a suspended sentence in six months
of probation
and then no charge no charges will be
filed in connection with the non-fatal
shooting of director Joel Souza who was
hit in the shoulder by the same bullet
that killed Alina oh [__]
damn it hurt someone else too that's so
same bullet damn were they like standing
behind each like that and just went
through no definitely standing a 90
degree angle to the side it got
ricocheted
the same logic you might want to claim
that one same Naked Gun logic
fire at 90 degree angles what is this
assault yeah
that's what it is but it's just a 90
degree balance yeah Alec Baldwin does
know how to curve bullets do
this might be a dumb question but I'm
asking anyway do blanks and regular
bullets look the same or do they look
cool there's a there's a jacket yeah
even the box is completely different
don't get mad at me I didn't know okay
leave it on set you're not even supposed
to have blanks yeah or that's about the
real real ones live oh the library yeah
you're not supposed to have live rounds
on stuff you want to just have them just
hanging around
just in case there are some sets that
don't even allow blanks oh really like
they do it in V like special effects or
whatever that's why that's why there's
no recoil in some movies where the guy's
shooting and the gun's perfectly still
yeah and they have to you just see
muzzle flash yeah and he's just like
yeah
just a little like I feel like John
Wicks especially the amount at which
he's like rolling around just popping
foals in the forehead and stuff like
that like I'm guessing that's not even
blinks that's just like CG because
they're right up on his [__] crop gun
that when you push the trigger it just
shakes so it looks like it's I mean
airsoft guns do that nowadays yeah the
blowback ones you got to do that because
[__] time crisis in the arcade can do
that yeah it can do that it like goes
like this it does time cries that was
one of my [__] favorite guns because
you know you'd always pick up the
[__] plastic one it's connected to
this like 18 foot chain and then if it
doesn't have recoil you're like man this
game is [__] fake when you pick up
time cries and that's just like
the property see they didn't have budget
for Time Crisis guns because they cut
costs yeah we only have budget for real
guns dang it I will take it I still like
the explosion guys
I'll turn the timer on that guy just
gets hired for every [__] movie for
summer
Dynamite drone activator for this it's
the SAG scale
Dynamite best or everyone's okay you got
to pay that twenty dollars extra
yeah twenty dollars that's the
difference between whether this set has
land mines
the more you pay the less booby traps
all right that's five dollars for the
tripwire twenty dollars for the
landmines you got actors being like man
this is my dream job but like this might
be my only job there's all these
landmines
it's just straight up booby trap I know
10 bucks or this doorknob's gonna be
burning hot
movie studios hate this guy
one simple trick
is Mr saw like what's going on
dude that's why there's no student films
of warm War films yeah that's true we
couldn't afford it everyone just died
um so yeah to to what bar was saying
earlier it does say that Helena's
widower Matthew Hutchins settled with
Baldwin and the production and actually
became an executive producer on the film
well he settled so fast yeah he gave a
producer credits like that's it that's
why the video is so weird because you
see him like smiling and he's like
crying and he's like this is what I
wanted does he get anything else like
out besides also like if you get
producer credits when you weren't even a
producer it doesn't even count people
know that you just got it just because
of the situation so it's like that that
holds no value unless your next film is
a documentary about that moment oh yeah
that's a credit to do that is it is that
just so he gets points for the residuals
oh maybe as an EP maybe maybe there's
something he's gonna get money off of it
he should make a YouTube video my wife
died and I got producer credits what
happens at the when they show this movie
what happens at the point point where
the scene comes up where he gets where
she actually gets shot will they even
show this movie yeah they're not gonna
release it aren't they I think it's
gonna do well because everyone's got to
watch it dude I want to see this movie
this is definitely the best Market are
they gonna break the fourth wall at that
moment and he just goes you guys know
what happens next
that'd be crazy but I want to see the
movie now because I'm like this movie
better be [__] good it's probably not
it's probably now what's gonna happen in
Hollywood is all the actors have to make
the bang noise while they shoot
the bang Flags I think that's what's
funny is that even you know with this
thing happening there's hella rappers
from music videos real guns going how
the hell do you make mistake like that
they have real loaded guns with the
finger on the trigger real loaded guns
on the set of so many rap music videos
they're all like they're so
irresponsible Alec Baldwin we have live
guns and we don't shoot each other
exactly true we got live guns with
extended mags or any lanes is like a
[__] idiot
[Laughter]
that Toy's like at least I got her in
the foot yeah dude I was making her
dance